brought Joe with you tonight what does
it mean for you to have him be here and
support you and how are you feeling
about your relationship right now it
means so much to have him here it's just
like the best support the best person to
calm me down and keep me calm and if I
end up crying I have a shoulder to cry
on so it's good I'm so happy that he's
here he was telling me if she's already
starting to think about what she's gonna
wear to your wedding I don't know why
she's thinking about I'm giving her the
bridesmaid dress she gonna be one of
your bridesmaids that's just my maid
about him I love this look I love this I
don't know why I decided to put myself
in a corset again it was like I thought
when the show was over I was just gonna
get rid of them but here I am here you
are you look sensational congratulations
it's the last game of Thrones season
premiere No I'm devastated and excited I
put on waterproof mascara tonight so I
know there's gonna be a lot of crying so
I'm ready I'm ready for it
Madras has such a huge fan time so many
celebrity fans it was the biggest
celebrity who's fangirled or fanboy
Dover yo Oh Barack Obama
yeah he loves Game of Thrones loves it
so that was pretty cool come on screen
brothers hosting SNL this weekend how do
you think he's gonna do
I think he's gonna do terribly he's not
funny he's not smart I think it's gonna
be terrible no I'm kidding he's gonna
kill her I'm so excited to see it how
are you feeling about what's next for
you you've got so much coming up I'm I
feel I feel good about it I don't know I
like petrified it's it's a lot for me
but I'm excited I'm excited for the
world to kind of see the next chapter of
my life post Game of Thrones and I feel
like a new woman
[Music]